the Central Western is filled with
personalities during the single cup and
today I am with one twitch streamer her
name is called a story she's very very
personable very likable on the twitch so
welcome welcome to st. Louis this is the
first time here in st. Louis tell us how
did you hear about this event and what
made you come here you know ever since I
started streaming just nine months ago
everybody asked me have you been a st.
Louis yet so I want y'all during the
u.s. championship but overall I didn't
work out to last-minute for me and what
else and to come to this event what are
your first impressions of st. Louis and
of the same with chess club and how do
you feel meeting all these like
celebrity chess players it's been great
I mean everywhere you go is like chess
related which is definitely a new
experience to me but it's been amazing
meeting everyone in person a lot of
these players
I mean hikaru streams also so meeting
her car for the first time with like
incredible and Bobby I'm at Fabio ppl
but hanging out with all these chess
players it's really incredible and last
question who is your favorite to win
this event my favorite the safe bet
thank you very much goal a storyteller
your fans where can they find you on
Twitch they can find me at twitch TV -
gold dust story there you have it
back to you guys